- Oh!
- Oh (laughs in disbelief) no!
- Yo!
- Wow!
(techno music)
- Honestly, I don't know
that much about Kanye West.
- What?
(Other man laughs)
Oh my God!
- I am excited by his music but
everything else he does, I kinda hate.
- When you think of Kanye, you think of
something shocking, new.
- I think creatively, he's brilliant.
As a person, sometimes, he seems to be
a little rough around the edges.
- We all know that Taylor lied now.
- Ooh, I'm so excited! (laughing)
- Here we go.
- Alright.
- Ooh, ooh.
- This is like so
eighties aerobic video.
(laughing in disbelief)
- I think I need to thirst follow
Teyana Taylor on Instagram now.
- It's definitely sexy.
- Yeah.
- How does she do that?
- She looks like Tomb Raider.
- She's a beast.
- Yes she is.
- Ooh, underboob is very--
- We're just looking at the lighting.
- She probably ran track--
- No.
- Some time in her life.
- How are you feeling?
- Great.
- It would take like eight
of my butts to do that.
- Wow.
- Holy (beep.)
- I'm not complaining.
- No, not at all.
- I thought it was just gonna encapsulate
the male gaze so perfectly, but it's not.
She's like in this gym, she's
athletic, she's really strong.
- I love watching people dancing alone.
I think there's a certain amount
of confidence that goes with that.
- Is it the end?
(both yelling in disbelief)
What the--
- Showers!
- Shower!
- Damn.
- I wish he was going
down on her right there.
Cause I think she deserves it after that.
(other person laughing)
- What?
- Huh?
She's a cat now?
- She's a cat?
Wait, what the (beep?)
- Why, why? But--
- I liked it.
I liked it a lot.
- What is this?
- I don't know, I guess she's a cat
and they're all oiled up.
- A lot of question--
What, what made the shift
to the cat face? What--
- All of the sheep--
- Sheep--
- Are followers.
- Yeah. Oh!
- I don't even know what
the words were about,
I was just looking at
sweaty, bouncing butt.
- Yep.
- Kanye does make stuff that immediately
becomes part of the cultural lexicon.
This last image was from this video
and I saw it all over Twitter.
- It's inspiring because it's so cool
to see a woman who's that
confident and strong--
- Yeah.
- Like killing it.
- Her whole dance was about exuding power.
- I can never achieve that body.
- Yeah, I mean this is still a person.
It shouldn't be held as a standard.
- I'm always excited
for Kanye's next thing
cause God knows what it's gonna be.
- Black excellence!
(both laughing)